ist einfach eine magische Lösung weil
jemand anders die Arbeit für einen macht
um kochenergie zu produzieren ja
Küchenabfälle sind voller Energie die
kann man nutzen um daraus Biogas zu
produzieren da musste ich mir schon
einige Sprüche anhören von meinen
Kollegen damals an der Uni von wegen
bist wahnsinnig
mein Name ist Katrin Pütz ich würde mich
als Erfinderin von biogastechnologien
bezeichnen und als Unternehmerin
[Musik]
um eigene Biogasanlage betreiben zu
können braucht man ein bisschen Platz ja
dann brauchst Du irgendwie ein Garten
man braucht überschüssiges Wasser ab
Wasser was man verwenden kann wo man
braucht natürlich Substrat also
organisches Material womit man die
Anlage füttern kann also entweder
Küchenabfälle fünf bis zehn Kilo am Tag
oder 20 Kilo Kuhmist oder Pferdemist
oder anderen tierdungen das bräuchte man
schlucken wenn man Biogas produziert aus
Küchenabfällen kriegt man ungefähr
einen Kubikmeter Biogas aus 10 Kilo
Küchenabfällen
damit kann man zwei bis vier Stunden
kochen
also ich habe viel Zeit auf dem Hof von
meiner Großmutter verbracht und habe
Agrar studiert habe sehr viel mit Tieren
gearbeitet also das ist wirklich
Mist von Wiederkäuern oder misst von
Pflanzenfressern ist nicht eklig
da sieht man
den
Behälter in dieser weiße Sack ist die
eigentliche Biogasanlage und man sieht
die ist richtig schön voll da ist jetzt
auch richtig viel Gas drin
genau und hier kommt das Material von
diesem Eimer runter und fließt unten an
der Anlage rein und wird jetzt in diesem
ganzen Behälter
vergoren oder abgebaut ja und bewegt
sich jeden Tag ein Stückchen weiter
Richtung Auslass da muss man noch eine
Gasleitung legen und irgendwo den den
speichersack deponieren und das war es
eigentlich also es geht Tasche
[Musik]
in diesem gärsack sind anaerobe
Bakterien und die bauen jegliches
organische Substrat ab zu CO2 und Methan
und das ist dann eben unser Biogas
biogas ist eine Systemlösung ja das ist
keine Lösung nur für Energiegewinnung
sondern das ist Energiegewinnung aus
Reststoffen das heißt wir verarbeiten
Reststoffe und produzieren organischen
Dünger also um den Gera ist rauszuholen
kann man einfach diesen 90 Grad Bogen
jetzt runter drehen und dann kommt der
raus
von ganz alleine und den kann man nehmen
ist jetzt ein schöner flüssiger Dünger
den kann man nehmen um damit direkt den
Garten zu düngen
ich mache jetzt mal
[Musik]
ich versuche mit meiner Art zu leben den
kleinstmöglichen Schaden anzurichten
wenn man es auf die 8,x Milliarden
verteilt sieht hat einfach jeder nur
eine gewisse Menge an Energie oder
Ressourcen die ihr verbrauchen kann und
warum nutzen wir das so stark aus und
verbrauchen so viel mehr im Vergleich zu
Menschen die eben diese Möglichkeit gar
nicht haben
diese Technik wurde ursprünglich für
Afrika entwickelt weil dort kochenergie
da so einen großen Teil der
Haushaltsenergie ausmacht ich habe im
Agrartechnik Studium Biogas
kennengelernt war aber vorher schon
einige Zeit in Afrika gewesen und habe
dann die Verknüpfung im Prinzip gemacht
zwischen der Energiesituation in der
viele Menschen stecken und der der
Einfachheit des Biogas Prinzips aber mit
der Bedingung dass man das eben nicht
auf Entwicklungshilfe basiert sondern
wirklich eigenständig und
unternehmerisch umsetzt
[Musik]
der Biogas Rucksack ist her drucklos ja
deshalb legt man da ein kleines Gewicht
drauf damit das Gas einfach Richtung
Brenner fließt und das habe ich jetzt
gerade gemacht da musste ich mir schon
einige Sprüche anhören von meinen
Kollegen damals eine Uni von wegen Gas
in der Tüte bist du wahnsinnig ja das
habe ich oft gehört
[Musik]
also und alle Leute eure Biogas Kochen
würden würden sie erstens mal viel Geld
sparen im Moment ja aber
fürs Klima kann man sagen
würde man sehr viel CO2 einsparen und
[Musik]
einfach jeden Tag Spaß zu kochen weil
man denkt okay cool ich Verbraucher ist
überhaupt nichts ja das kommt gerade aus
meinem eigenen Müll
ja der Brenner ist meine eigene
Entwicklung das ist patentiert in vielen
Ländern und es ist tatsächlich der
einfachste Gasbrenner den es so auf dem
Markt gibt
den allerdings für Deutschland
zertifizieren zu lassen ce-zertifizieren
zu lassen oder für Europa ist eine
Riesenherausforderung weil die
bestehenden Gesetze und Vorschriften für
erdgasgeräte gemacht sind und keiner
will Biogas Geräte testen deshalb
kriegen wir keine Zertifizierung wir
warten wird anderthalb Jahren auf das
Ergebnis obwohl wir alle
sicherheitsrelevanten praktischen Tests
bestanden haben in diesem Brenner und es
ist eindeutig eine regulierungsproblem
[Musik]
also die Biogasanlage ist im Prinzip
eine Imitation von einem kuhmagen kann
man sagen ja und eine Kuh hat eine
Temperatur von ich weiß nicht 36 bis 38
Grad ja und genau das versuchen wir in
der Biogasanlage nachzuahmen und deshalb
muss man in unserem breiten Biogasanlage
eigentlich heizen und wir haben eine
solare
Fußbodenheizung darunter die eben genau
38 Grad
an Wärme liefert im Sommer wenn man
überschüssigen Solarstrom hat aber im
Winter wird das nicht funktionieren
deshalb bauen wir gerade einen biomiler
mit dem restlichen Stroh von unserem
Strohballenhaus das wäre gebaut haben
und jetzt verarbeiten wir das zusammen
mit Pferde bist und Grünschnitt zu einem
Biomeiler der dann eben Warmwasser
produzieren wird
[Musik]
ja die Vielfalt ja die die diese Arbeit
mit sich bringt das ist das was mir Spaß
macht mir macht es auch Spaß am Computer
zu arbeiten aber nicht die ganze Zeit
warm
hoffentlich wird auch der bioweiler warm
okay also
diesen Ablauf noch fertig machen
ich mache gerne Sachen die
technisch einfach sind und Sinne geben
aber das mache ich wirklich zum ersten
Mal
und vor allem in Kombination mit einer
Biogasanlage
wenn sich das hier bewährt mit dem
biomiler dann würde ich das gerne eben
das das Wissen und die Erfahrung dann
weitergeben an unsere Kunden die
biogastechnik von uns kaufen genau
das wäre das Ziel
dann heizen im Winter das Problem ist
einfach noch nicht gelöst
als ich den Hermann das erste Mal
gefragt habe ob ich sein Pferdemist
haben kann hat er sich gewundert und
wollte sie ganz genau wissen was ich
damit mache und jetzt bringt er mir
sogar Pferdemist wenn ich gar nicht
danach Frage der ist Bruder sein muss
ist
ich fahre jetzt nach Köln zu einem
Termin mit Geschäftspartnern aus der
Schweiz und da fahre ich hin mit Biogas
wenn das Auto anspringt okay
[Musik]
ich arbeite mit Vertriebspartnern in
vielen verschiedenen Ländern und so
mache ich das auch in Deutschland ich
verkaufe nicht direkt an Endkunden
sondern ich beliefer meinen
Vertriebspartner der sich dann um die
Endkunden kümmert
hier ist unsere Lagerstätte für die
biogastechnik hier wird verpackt und in
Zukunft werden hier die Rucksäcke
produziert
sind das die Rucksäcke für Spanien das
sind die Rucksäcke für Spanien
ich habe die Anlage nicht speziell für
den europäischen Markt entwickelt
sondern die Nachfrage ist jetzt gerade
einfach explodiert kann man sagen
was ich oft tatsächlich mache ist
einfach noch irgendwie keine Ahnung
viele Grüße oder so drauf schreiben
hallo Stefan
ja ich habe ein ganz schlechten Empfang
tut mir leid gut dann bis gleich ja
Tschüss
ich freue mich total darauf dass
Schweizer Vertriebspartner kommen die in
der Schweiz ohne Griechenland unsere
Technik auf Markt bringen wollen weil
die Energiekrise macht nötig dass mehr
Leute Zugang zu unseren Technik bekommen
hallo grüß euch
Stefan grüß Dich Korea wie war die Fahrt
und wer bist du der hallo dir Christus
schön dass Ihr da seid gehen wir rein ja
vor 12 Jahren hätte ich niemals gedacht
dass ich das jemals in Deutschland oder
in Europa umsetzen werde und das ist
dafür eine Nachfrage gegeben wird aber
das jetzt Menschen aus der Schweiz
kommen und gerne Vertriebspartner werden
wollen ist natürlich eine große Ehre der
einzige Knackpunkt ist jetzt noch die
CE-Zertifizierung für den Brenner die
uns noch fehlt ohne die können wir nicht
expandieren
es ist keine one size-fits all Lösung es
ist nicht was was jeder auf der Welt
machen kann es gibt auf jeden Fall genug
Leute die davon wahrscheinlich aufgrund
ihrer Wohnsituation einfach
ausgeschlossen sind aber wenn es
wenigstens die machen die es können
hätten wir schon wirklich was geworden
ist die einzige Lösung aber auf jeden
Fall eine die viele Leute umsetzen
können und ein kleines Puzzleteil von
unserer Energiewende wir brauchen mehr
ehrliche Jobs fürs Klima kennst du einen